welcome to this video playing brainy
Smurf brainy Smurf from Germany no name
okay let's see yeah the Catalan can
still go to the bull go maybe I can get
a bit on him for for a different type of
position yep benoni fianchetto when only
brainy Smurf tile asked me if he's going
to be on YouTube yeah sure okay so what
how do you play that you I forgot it I
think it was like this a 6a 497 it's
been yes that I looked at to add this
opening mh3 rights rookie aid probably
with beef I'm coming and now you've got
Knight e5 and I be six years 95 is the
autumn coach like a spar of game we came
I don't know that maybe he could have
taken on d6 I think i blundered this
before okay oops Bishop d7 oh this is
the idea intending Knight takes e4 am
NOT a four-night a4 b5 the idea
hmm yeah I don't really have any
experience with this opening I know what
a bit because I had looked at this ages
ago when I studied the Catalan that's
why that in this move order you need to
have some antidote against c5 and not
going to the Benoni is really very lame
yeah but now night xfr-s is really the
move maybe maybe but Bishop f4 is really
irritating me and then later later stage
also if i take here night a four-night
a4 b5 this is going to play night c5
what is this 95 dc5 and then Bishop f4
yeah no idea
maybe I can just move it okay he
anticipated this fall asleep but I
really don't know how to continue after
that that's even Bishop f4 here but then
i can probably take on a forfeit should
be six take on be too yeah okay Maggie I
need to I need to take oh no choice and
now Bishop f4 yeah I don't know do I
just move the rook yeah maybe I can just
move the rock I mean the way the night
h5 is an instant idea after he's got the
bishop f-fine Bishop f4 v6e 59 h5 or
something along these lines obviously
this is a super unbalanced position with
the three pawns against one porn and
white having the complete center it it
might be suspicious oh oh this is
surprising I didn't consider that at all
of course Bishop f4 now wins the
exchange but this looks very air yeah
this doesn't look right from a dynamic
point of view 9 h 5 or how do i
sacrifice it I don't know
98 yeah it doesn't release for any I
want to force him to take so that we
have some clarity in this I didn't
consider that at all because now I've
got this monster bishop and his Center
lost all its dynamism at least for the
moment here we are probably to go to f5
and deform yeah let's let's advance
night f5 coming he's got the deep on
this is some really what makes White's
position playable other than that he
will get into trouble maybe can play G
for him to be an ideology for to prevent
Knight to f5 maybe g4 Bishop g5 he's got
F for only one smell does you want to
Austin be porn maybe but i have c 3 so i
don't really mind okay you prepared that
if i go b4 b4 Knight takes Queen 85 this
is a pinup hard to get rid of maybe with
G form
Jacqueline not that's not news on time I
wasn't sure night before Queen 85g for
something like that mixing also night go
into a foreign in this night before
Queen 85 Queen f or I can just take
before but this geofoam that mutates me
the combination of g4 and cuneiform yeah
here I thought c3 would be good here ok
let's go ahead
okay where I can play b3m it takes a
taxi to look sir disastrous now I forgot
about that BA the saying what the heck I
hope I didn't give it away with this
move this would be real shame I win
white got completely outplayed here f 6m
not what you want to play
yeah must must do that and what else
yeah Bishop 6 okay but does it help what
a load of crap unbeliever just this is
this bloody pin here yeah what the heck
it's not too not even a pin here can't
think here time Barney yeah the only
thing helping me is that is queen is a
bit of chocolate this is again good for
me I think all kinds of stuff is hey now
check
Bishop g3 is a big threat check
checkmate whoo why those kind of games
was 8 sec meeting with no time on the
clock I always married tricky yeah this
went from from a complete window to a
loss when I overlooked this this is this
luke hanging on v8 yeah this is some
just excellent for black but I really I
really forgot that is this thing is
hanging so here when I played b3 I need
to play something else III gets me into
trouble or at least it spoil at some the
fun then flat maybe this move I mean he
needs to go to if he needs to go to h2
then yeah I can take I'm sorry hey this
is this is actually good but not easy at
all with the limited time the computer
points it out here is a leap of course
look at this and like wins but you still
need to to find that likes winning
because of those this combination is
it's just deadly something like that so
fantastic for black so this one day 5
I've got four pawns for the work and the
fantastic position very be known you
like where the queenside pawns do the
job yet I overlooked that you can take
simply and here it is probably just the
wind for why
yeah plus 3 plus 4 Adam yeah he already
has spoiled a bit but I guess the real
problem comes here he he cannot take on
be too he needs to play something else
f5 is the good move and d5 hangs but it
a 5 seems to be the solution check not
easy to play but this already jack yeah
it's a strong computer gives the draw
here I'm winning but it says look be a
check this is what I expected of this is
a draw using the pin yeah yeah this is
what I expected but he played down
rookie 2 and now blacks winning chatting
yeah this is indefensible King g7 was I
didn't know what to do they wanted to
keep Queen f3 is stronger I just wanted
to get the King out and give this a
dessert it still wins this this is a
mate already check checkmate yeah
interesting game i hope you enjoyed it
thanks for watching